I think uh the best result is if you
combine all those signals together. Um
like if you combine modalities like if
you you know have a signal on whether
the face looks AI generated and a signal
on whether the voice is AI generated.
What we found is you know you combine
those things you get a better result
than either one independently. Um, and
you know, if you have a whole detection
pipeline that takes into account, um,
for example, you know, the email address
of the person you're on a Zoom call
with, um, and combine that with these,
uh, I guess more like, you know, new
technology features like the AI
generated or not type stuff, uh, you
know, all that stuff kind of ensembles
together and then you can get a more
comprehensive picture. So the old stuff
is useful, the new stuff is useful. If
you combine them all together, that's I
think um how you can get the the biggest
the best best results I suppose.
[Music]
Lucas who welcome to the human zero day.
Thank you so much for joining the
speaker series. I really appreciate your
time and the energy you're you're going
to invest with me over this short
conversation. So, thank you very much.
>> Yeah. Yeah. No, thank you, Michael.
>> So, so Lucas, you're a obviously a
technologist. You've you're in the
cutting edge of machine learning and
artificial intelligence. You're devoting
so much of your time and energy today to
the context of fishing, social
engineering across what looks to be
different modalities which I think is
one of the really interesting pillars of
the evolution of social engineering and
fishing as they now come out in all
shapes and forms from websites to videos
to phone calls to emails and SMSs. uh
the attack vectors are seem to just be
expanding across the channels and they
seem to be getting more and more
sophisticated. And before we dive into
that, please walk me through a little
bit your own journey of how you got
here. How do you end up choosing to
devote your time and energy to this
problem?
>> Yeah. So I originally came pretty much
purely from like a AI ML background. Um,
so studied computer science and then
electrical engineering at USC and pretty
much the whole time I was focused on a
IML. Did some research related to that.
Um, and then I ended up interning at
Palo Alto Networks. Not that I was into
cyber security beforehand, but when I
got there, I I found out that I really
liked it. Um, and it was interesting to
see like not just, you know, how a IML
could be used, but I thought the space
itself was just so interesting. Um, and
especially the evolution of it, moving
from like, you know, low-level malware
and then gradually attacks have kind of
moved up the chain to more like social
engineering and actually attacking like
people's psychology rather than how
machines work. Um, and I thought that
was really interesting. Like I really
enjoy learning how the attackers try to
frame things. So I decided to just stay
in the field. Uh, and that's where I am
now.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I mean one of the things
that I often um share with people it's
such an interesting evolution looking
from firewalls in 95 to malware like
with the semantics and then eventually
to cloud security and then identity and
all of a sudden we it's like we're going
up and up all the way to the human mind
and uh and and it's super fascinating
and tell me a little bit about your work
with duet uh because uh I I have because
I I like I mentioned to you I think it's
such a cool endeavor that that you've
been a part of. Tell me a little bit
about what that's about.
>> Yeah, this is something uh I helped
start as as a student when I was at USC
uh with a few other of my friends there.
Um we actually we visited some refugee
camps in Greece as a part of a class. Um
and we saw that there was a lot of stuff
that was being donated that wasn't
really being used. Uh and at the same
time, the refugees weren't really
getting the exact items they wanted. Uh,
so my way of describing it is it's sort
of like a way that refugees can directly
request the things they need from stores
in their community and then you as a
donor can browse those exact items and
then pay for them online. So check it
out. It's at gived.org. Still active.
Um, but yeah, it was just a cool side
project that we're still going on with.
>> Amazing. So, so let's dive into social
engineering and fishing. You are living
at the cutting edge of it. you're at the
forefront. Um the scale at which you're
operating it looks like from a detection
perspective is is quite is quite amazing
and probably gives you a really good
firsthand glance at what we're seeing in
the world today. So paint me a picture
of what are the types of social
engineering and fishing attacks that
you're observing that are out there
right now.
>> Yeah, there's a few different ways of
thinking about it. I think one helpful
one is on the one hand you have like
very mass non-targeted fishing campaigns
all the way to like very very
hyperargeted spear fishing attacks. I
think that's probably the most helpful
axis. So in terms of volume uh in terms
of like what we detect you know
obviously the mass stuff is just going
to have higher detection volume but that
stuff usually tends to be easier to
detect. And then, you know, the further
you move toward kind of the hyperargeted
direction, the lower volume you're going
to have because it just takes more
effort to craft those attacks, but you
know, obviously like higher percent of
success. Um, and it's more difficult to
detect as well. So, actually with deep
fake stuff, we also see kind of both
sides of the spectrum. we see, you know,
kind of mass deep fake scams that are
just, you know, popular
investing in crypto a YouTube
advertisement or something like that.
Um, that's just a total scam, you know,
all the way to like, you know, super
targeted. Someone calls you on WhatsApp
and is voice cloning your boss or
something like that. So, that is a thing
as well. And how new or how new is this
in terms of the development cycle of the
type the sophistication and the modality
of attacks? You've been at this for a
few years. What what's been your
impression of even if we just take the
last year or two? What's changed over
the last 12 to 24 months?
Yeah, I mean obviously AI has blown up
in the last two years or so and deep
fakes are um obviously a big part of
that. So I think the the trends we're
seeing with regards to that are much
higher quality uh fishing emails that
can be generated using LLMs. Um that is
something we see although it's hard to
determine exactly if something is AI
generated or not but I'm fairly certain
that attackers are doing that. Um, and
then you know with regards to the social
social engineering side, being able to
either clone someone's voice or
potentially their face, although the
face part is a little more difficult to
do in real time, but the voice is more
feasible. So those are kind of new types
of attacks that we have to be wary of.
Yeah, you know, I've seen that recent
statistics from the teammate um
investment group that have shown that
credential fishing has been up about
1,200% over the last year, fishing
emails about a,000%.
And the number of malicious emails on a
daily basis now is north of 3 billion
where more than about half of them are
LLM based which I think is really really
interesting you know considering that
until I guess 4 years ago the vast
majority of them probably more than 90%
were really bad spelling with some
country from Africa needing some aid.
Right.
>> Right.
Yeah. Yeah. No, I mean it's it's so easy
to just, you know, write a script that
generates a, you know, million different
fishing emails now.
So, so Lucas, as you think through from
a technology perspective, as you think
through this landscape and where we're
at, because obviously we we don't want
to be in a world where we're just
consumed by fishing and social
engineering. What are you observing and
how are you framing your thinking around
potential ways to start mitigating this
threat?
So I think with AI it prevents you know
obviously the challenges are this the
scale of attacks and the variety of
attacks that been that can be created
but it can also be very helpful on the
defense side. Um so you know a lot of
our detection components now will use
LLMs as you know maybe not the core
driver but as a as a component in a part
of a broader detection pipeline. Um so
it's a very useful tool for the defense
side as well. Uh and in addition, it
actually turns out that a lot of
traditional um defense techniques can
even be applied to these new sorts of
attacks as well. So with things like
email, uh if you still see you know a
lot of suspicious emails coming from a
small set of email addresses or you know
maybe a suspicious domain, those signals
are still very useful. Like the fact
that the email itself is AI generated
doesn't mean that those signals are
going to go away. Uh even same thing
with like deep fakes, right? Um if
someone is, you know, logging into Zoom
from a domain that does not match your
company email, uh and is for example
claiming to be like your boss or your
executive or something like that, that
signal is still very useful. So with the
new generation of attacks, uh the
traditional signals are still useful um
even if you know there's like a new
layer on top of them. And so so it
sounds like there's there's the
traditional signal, you know, you can
look at the the IP, the networking, the
devices, and look at more traditional
ideas of how you would think through and
I guess an authenticated source or
verified device. And then there is also
the newer schools of thought looking at,
you know, the the pixels, looking at the
audio signals. Do do you have a
perception of of how this space is
forming in terms of feasibility for one
or the other also looking a little bit
ahead as to you know how fast these
things are moving what what would be fe
feasible from a technology perspective.
Yeah, I mean I think uh the best result
is if you combine all those signals
together. Um like if you combine
modalities like if you you know have a
signal on whether the face looks AI
generated and a signal on whether the
voice is AI generated. What we found is
you know you combine those things you
get a better result than either one
independently. Um, and you know, if you
have a whole detection pipeline that
takes into account, um, for example, you
know, the email address of the person
you're on a Zoom call with, um, and
combine that with these, uh, I guess
more like, you know, new technology
features like the AI generated or not
type stuff, uh, you know, all that stuff
kind of ensembles together and then you
can get a more comprehensive picture. So
the old stuff is useful, the new stuff
is useful. If you combine them all
together, that's I think um how you can
get the the biggest the best best
results I suppose.
>> And you know, I've been hearing a lot of
CISOs and security professionals look at
this space and are thinking to
themselves, boy, how how in the world,
you know, are is the defense going to
keep up with the attack? I mean thing
this I mean it just feels like there's
so much money and so much incentive for
the modalities to become more
sophisticated and for the attacks to
become more fragmented and and so much
fewer dollars being spent on on defense
then then they're they're wondering
whether to even look at detection as a
feasible defensive mechanism over time.
So what would you say to those CISOs
yourself? I mean I think obviously the
scale of attacks will increase and has
already been increasing but you know
that doesn't mean you just give up right
um I think if you take kind of like what
we think as we call it like a Swiss
cheese approach where you know a new
attack pops up and okay we'll create
like something that blocks maybe 90% of
those attacks but not all of them but if
you have a comprehensive enough uh
defense architecture defense strategy
eventually all these you
layers of Swiss cheese are going to
create, you know, somewhat of a solid
wall. So even though each layer itself
might have some holes and maybe some of
these attacks are going to slip through
some specific layer you have, if you
kind of stack up a bunch of layers of
defense, eventually it becomes really
hard for an attack to slip through all
of them. So, you know, there's still
hope and nothing's going to be perfect,
but it's still way better than just
letting anything come into your network.
>> Absolutely. And and I love the Swiss
cheese analogy. So effectively to
picture it, you're saying, let's take a
slice of Swiss cheese that obviously has
some holes, but if you take an if you
create another layer of Swiss cheese,
which has a different set of holes, then
some of the solid layers will overlap
some of the empty ones. And over time,
if you build enough layers, then there
will be very few holes that are
perfectly aligned to let through. But
that raises I think another question
which is you know these these models are
aren't per perfect also in terms of
their false positive rates and one of
the concerns that I've been thinking
about is well you know what happens if
how do how do you manage the the
skepticism or the trust factor of these
models especially as many of them may be
you know deep neural networks or or
blackbox models. How do you then
mitigate your false positive rate so
that you don't end up sort of catching
everything as as potentially suspicious
and then you're you're not catching
other side of the coin.
>> Yeah. I mean that's that's very
difficult especially when it comes to
like uh deep fake detection. I think
that task just as a pure machine
learning like is it AI generated or not
task is much more difficult than
something like uh generic fishing
webpage detection. So you know in terms
of like the false positive to true
positive trade-off you're not going to
get like as optimal a results as you
know some of the easier ML tasks out
there but it's still something. It's
still a useful signal. And I think this
is where it comes back to like combining
a lot of signals together. Maybe if one
model independently, you can't take its
verdict at face value, but if you have
other signals you can combine it with uh
and either onse them together or have
like a cascading model type of approach,
um then you can really do better than
you know a single model alone. Um so
yeah, that's one way of going about it.
Um it's very tricky. Obviously, it's
something we deal with a lot cuz, you
know, we process like a billion web
pages per day. If we have a false
positive rate of 1%, that's, you know,
like a million web pages that just got
blocked. So, yeah, it's tricky.
>> Yeah, I think it's kind of amazing to
think of, you know, when you say, yeah,
we, you know, 1% false positive, it
doesn't sound like a lot when you're
actually looking at
>> when you're actually looking at that
scale. Well, that's that's not feasible
anymore. I I'm and I'd love to get your
perspective on, you know, if we're
looking at it from an from an enterprise
perspective and and a business
perspective. I mean, so there's one
thing to catch the mass the mass social
engineering attacks. Um and then there's
the more targeted attacks which are
really could you know potentially
>> take down an organization if they get
through you know if somebody gets access
to a sensitive um sensitive system or or
do one of those very large fraudulent
transactions.
How are you thinking through the
evolution of this attack in the context
of you know business operations and you
know we we're doing everything digitally
today. So, what what what are we where
are we heading into?
>> Yeah. Um, so I'm not sure if the
audience has heard of this like $25
million Zoom deep fake hack that
happened I think about a year ago at
this point. Um, so we were thinking
about this and like even if someone was
able to deep fake such and such person,
the fact that they were still able to
get that transaction to go through maybe
implies that there weren't enough like
safeguards, not even on the cyber
security side, but just on the, you
know, on the operations side, right?
Like you really need to make sure that,
okay, like such and such person has to
sign off on this, you know, especially
for a big transaction like that. So it's
not just cyber security that's involved,
right? Even like on the operation side
like let's make sure this is really a
valid transaction that has to go
through. I personally don't know what
exactly that looks like but you know I'm
sure the business side people can figure
that out a bit more. Um and then with
regards to actually detecting these from
the cyber security side um it's
important to try to get visibility into
all different parts of the attack chain
if possible. Right? So, if the entry
point is like an email saying, "Hey, uh,
this is your boss. Can I set up a Zoom
call or something like that?" You want
to make sure you get visibility into
that? And then two, you know, if they
actually do have a Zoom meeting set up,
you want to try to get visibility into
that as well, right? Like, what is the
email address that's participating? Is
it actually from your organization or
not? Um, and you potentially, you know,
if you can get access to like the
transcript and things like that, even
better, cuz then you can see, okay, is
this person asking to send, you know, a
bank transfer? Cuz that's potentially
pretty suspicious. Um, right. And then
you go further on and then, okay, is
this bank transaction actually
legitimate or not? So, the greater
visibility you have into all different
parts of the chain, the greater chances
of you being able to catch that attack.
And that kind of goes back to like the
Swiss Swiss cheese analogy from earlier.
>> So it sounds like well you're we're
starting from the root problem which
would be there are these distinct use
cases where very critical events are
about to transpire within the
organization. You mentioned the $25
million heist which I by the way I fully
agree with you on that point. uh
probably you should have been caught
through procedures but uh but I think it
shines light on this context of it's it
in if we're looking at it more
holistically of how would we protect
trai know any financial transaction
given that let's say a big chunk of the
fishing scams are on financial
transactions probably having just a
detection piece at the end point
wouldn't suffice because of the Swiss
cheese analogy but if you were to have
systems in place that would be able to
cons to consolidate multiple signals
across the initial email conversation,
maybe even the LinkedIn message that
came through and then all going all the
way to the payroll to the payment or the
transaction software and have and
constantly validating uh then that would
hopefully you would catch at some point
in the chain within that six or sevenst
step process you would catch oh wait
there's actually something suspicious
here you should look right now into this
and uh and at least flag it so that a
human moderator would look into it. Is
that is that what you mean?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Totally right. Um so
either you can have all those steps
running independently. Best case
scenario, you figure out a way to
combine all those signals together and
then you know analyze like the
interaction and the chain from one step
to another. But even if you just run a
bunch of checks independently, that's
still way better than just you know
having a single check.
>> Absolutely. Well, and it would make
sense that if you had access to these
checks independently, taking an ensemble
approach would probably be the the uh
the ideal next step. Lucas, you know,
going, you know, now that you spent some
time into this, um, what do you enjoy
most about your work here?
>> It really keeps you on your toes. Um,
like right two or three years ago, you
could not have envisioned that like AI
generated malware would actually become
a real problem that we have to deal with
and something we have to consider. Um,
so yeah, I mean it evolved super
quickly. Like I think when I first
joined four or five years ago, um, I
really couldn't have envisioned the
projects that we're working on now. Um,
and especially the tool sets that are
available to us now, right? That is
constantly evolving as well. Like um,
all our teams are talking about how to
use LLMs in different parts of our
pipelines now. Not just cuz it's like,
you know, a hyped up thing, but it is
the projects we're working on now would
not have been possible like 2 or 3 years
ago. Um, the types of detections we're
doing, the types of like semantic
analysis we're doing just would not have
been possible 2, three years ago. Um,
and it's really cool because every new
technology that comes out translates
both to the attacker side and the
defense side. So, you're able to, you
know, see what attackers are doing and
also use those to build up new defenses.
So yeah, it's really exciting in that
way.
>> Super interesting. Lucas, I really want
to thank you for taking the time to uh
join me. Um really awesome conversation
went by way too fast. Um best of luck
with continuing to detect what at this
point is hundreds of thousands of uh
many different types of social
engineering and fishing attacks. So
thank you and uh have an amazing rest of
the day.
>> Thank you, Michael. That was a lot of
fun.